à chacun son effort de guerre
dans cette cuisine de la ville des
milliers de repas sont préparés chaque
jour pour les ukrainiens déplacés nico
est plat nourrissant mais surtout les
confortant
et les gens qui fuient l'est du pays ont
besoin d'un bon repas chaud dit ce chef
après plus de sept semaines de guerre la
mobilisation continue mais le
déracinement aussi
les jours de nouveaux visages pour leur
arrivée dans ce centre d'hébergement
les gens fuyant les violences de l'est
de l'ukraine
vlad a eu beaucoup de chance
il a profité d'une accalmie dans les
tirs d'artillerie russe pour quitter ses
déroutes donetsk avec des proches sa
ville est située dans le donbass sur la
ligne de front
beaucoup de gens que je connais ils sont
toujours certains ne veulent pas s'en
aller ils disent que c'est leur destin
d'y rester d'autres explique-t-il n'ont
pas accès au réseau de transport pour
s'échapper
des centaines de kilomètres séparent
youla 17 ans de son amoureux il
insistait pour qu elle quitte la région
de lougansk alors que lui est resté
derrière pour prendre soin de sa mère et
de sa grand mère
il craignait que je sois blessé parce
que des obus explosent est devant ma
maison quand on lui demande si elle veut
retourner chez elle
l'émotion est impossible à contenir
elle espère que sa maison et les autres
seront épargnés et que les gens pourront
rentrer chez eux
mais l'intensification des attaques
russes dans le dos de basse fait
craindre le pire vlad ne se fait pas
d'illusion
ne faut pas paniquer cela va durer le
temps on ne peut pas y échapper dit il
résigné
qu'ils soient jeunes ou plus âgés les
déplacés du clignet porte le même poids
celui de l'exil et de l'incertitude
ici louis do à radio-canada qui vive